all right guys i just voted yes i voted
yes on the recall and yes i voted for
larry elder to be the next governor of
california actually my ballot i did it
electronically and then you have to put
your paper ballot in it rejected it four
times and then it kicked me out of the
system and a guy came over they looked
at my ballot it actually misprinted the
print was all screwed up i actually have
photographic evidence of that and then
they wrote void on the back of my ballot
i have photographic evidence of that and
the pollster knew who i was so i'm not
making this up and then i had to
re-enter everything else i did it again
and it all did work the second time one
of the other interesting things at least
on the electronic machines here in los
angeles is that you click yes on recall
and then to get to larry elder's name
you have to press more
eight times eight times you have to
press on the screen more just to get to
larry elder's name just a little bit of
interesting info but anyway my ballot
misprinted was rejected four times they
voided it and i had to vote again didn't
have to show an id so all's good anyway
september 14th is the recall everybody
vote yes on the recall and vote for a
good man larry elder all right see ya if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell